este aumento demográfico exponencial de
los últimos dos siglos A qué se debe
Marcela bueno como nos anticipó hace un
momento a mal este es el resultado de la
transición demográfica que es ese
proceso que recoge la tendencia de
disminución de la fecundidad y
disminución de la mortalidad lo que pasa
es que usualmente sucede primero la
disminución de la fecundidad que Perdón
la disminución de la mortalidad como
acaba de señalar a mal que la de la
fecundidad Y entonces en ese momento
tenemos grandes crecimientos
poblacionales es decir cuando no tenemos
que disminuyan al mismo ritmo los dos
factores por los cuales crece
vegetativamente la población pues lo que
tenemos es que sigue llegando más gente
que la que se está muriendo por eso
tenemos explosiones demográficas y
Marcela usted me comentaba justo antes
sobre todo el crecimiento fue muy
acentuado en los primeros en las
primeras décadas no de estos últimos
siglos y que luego se ha ralentizado A
qué se debe claro el último los últimos
30 años hemos venido viendo una
disminución muy acelerada de este
crecimiento seguimos creciendo por eso
hoy conmemoramos los ocho mil millones
pero hemos venido viendo como estamos en
tazas de 1% anual lo que pues nos
muestra un crecimiento bastante menor
que el que estaba previsto anteriormente
De hecho comentábamos antes que según
las proyecciones anteriores Y vamos a
llegar al 2023 siendo alrededor de 15
mil millones y no los 8.000 que somos
hoy porque está pasando esto Pues porque
hemos visto reducciones en la fecundidad
mucho más aceleradas que las previstas
principalmente en los países
más desarrollados con mayor acceso
anticoncepción e incluso no solamente
digamos esto es visto como algo positivo
Porque queremos tener los hijos
solamente tenemos solamente los hijos
que queremos tener sino porque empiezan
a operar restricciones socioeconómicas
muy fuertes para delimitar la cantidad
de hijos que se que se quieren tener por
lo que hoy vemos en muchos países que
estamos por debajo de el índice de
reemplazo que es 2,1 hijos por mujer lo
que nos hace pensar Bueno qué va a pasar
este número de 8 mil millones parece
grande pero
podría estar en realidad lo que nos está
mostrando es que estamos creciendo muy
lentamente ahora claro y usted hablaba
de Estos factores de restricción de la
natalidad podría darse un momento en que
Estos factores operarán a todo el mundo
en la mayor parte del planeta y
empezáramos a ver un decrecimiento
porque según las proyecciones de na la
cifra la población mundial se
estabilizaría por ahí a la década entre
2080 y 2100 No claro pues yo creo que
aquí es un panorama muy diverso el que
tenemos en términos de la fecundidad
mundial por un lado tenemos las altas
tasas en África que si bien han
disminuido como en todo el planeta pues
siguen siendo importantes y siguen
aportando mucha población al mundo e
incluso también en otros países o en
otras zonas al interior de los mismos
países que son las zonas más privadas en
términos de acceso anticoncepción
más privados en términos socioeconómicos
Pero por otro lado también tenemos
en contraste son las en las que tenemos
por un lado mucha restricción para
tener la cantidad de hijos que se sueñan
o para formar familia y por otro lado
pues la perfección de la estructura Es
decir de la composición por edad de las
poblaciones porque allí donde tenemos
mayor cantidad de personas viejas mayor
cantidad de personas mayores que pesan
de manera importante en el total de la
población pues allí vamos a tener Por
ende menos posibilidad de re menos
digamos que capacidad reproductiva no
porque tendremos menos gente en edades
fecunda